Sam the person do you think he's he's  obviously brilliant and smart and was  able to get away with a lot of stuff but  was he a criminal from the onset did he  just make some foolish mistakes mentally  where was he throughout all this  Sam's he's like the 14 year old kid that  stole the family car he doesn't have a  driver's license he got he got you know  eight of his high school friends in the  car and then he found out that there's  like a hundred thousand dollars of cash  a bunch of drugs and a gun in the car  and then they went George Saturday night  wow you know and and entire thing ends  you know horrifically with the car  wrapped around a tree half the people  but that analogy I think it's very  important to clarify that analogy and  maybe he's an honor student in high  school but the point is he was not ready  to drive the car